nous sommes en direct ce soir avec
cécile relax député la république en
marge de la 3ème circonscription du val
d'oise
bonsoir madame merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france aaa
face à vous eric bockel sénateur du
parti communiste français du nord
bonsoir monsieur bockel
merci à tous les deux jeux de participer
à ce débat en direct vous avez suivi je
les imagine cette longue intervention du
président de la république sur le média
brut cécile erignac
pourquoi selon vous at il fait le bon
choix d'ailleurs de s'exprimer sur sur
ce média alternatif en ligne
c'est un choix qui est intéressant
lorsqu'on veut s'adresser à notre
jeunesse
aujourd'hui c'est brut ccc le média qui
est suivie par beaucoup de nos jeunes et
on voit bien que depuis depuis quelques
temps on a dû le président voulait
renouer avec cette jeunesse et ce média
l'appareil en effet opportun oui ça a
été très suivi il ya eu beaucoup de
commentaires et rythme auquel votre
sentiment sur sur son intervention sur
brut était très honnêtement je n'ai pas
écouté cette interview si j'étais en
séance au sénat j'y retourne dans un
quart d'heure on est sur les missions
budgétaires j'ai simplement vu quelques
extraits dont vous avez fait écho les jt
de 20 heures j'ai jeté un oeil % un peu
ce qu'ils disaient mais il est temps de
sortir de la stricte communication parce
que les moments de communication on en a
déjà eu
le grand débat avec les gilet jaune qui
a fait suite à cette crise profonde dont
les causes à mon avis n'ont pas disparu
non plus on a eu des semaines de débats
à grand renfort de communication pour
accoucher d'une souris au bout et qui
font aujourd'hui les éléments et les
ferments de la crise n'ont pas disparu
de cette société mais je pense qu'on y
reviendra
c'est celle réelle vous voulez réagir
c'est vrai que demain il ya encore une
manifestation contre cet article 24 de
la loi sécurité globale
le chef de l'état finalement n'a pas dit
grand chose quant à une potentielle
suppression de cet article 24 doit-il a
retiré selon vous c'est normal que chef
de l'état n'intervienne pas puisque nous
sommes sur un texte législatif c'est un
texte qui à partir aux parlementaires
c'est une proposition de loi donc
d'ailleurs notre mon collègue sénateur
participera je pense aux débats sur
cette future loi qui arrivera au sénat
c'est c'est aux parlementaires de
continuer le travail
le gouvernement s'est exprimé au sujet
de l'article 24 mois je vais partie des
parlementaires qui ont voté contre
donc voilà on doit continuer le
processus parlementaire sur cette
proposition de loi sécurité globale i
lya et je suis la première à dire
beaucoup de choses à dire sur l'article
24 j'étais favorable à sa suppression
donc moi je serais pas du tout du tout
choqué à ce qu'on le retire parce qu'en
effet cet article 24 suscite énormément
énormément de et d'émotions et de
questions qui sont tout à fait
justifiées et mon collègue parlementaire
sénateurs ne pourra que se poser
également ces questions là dessus je
pense qu on se rejoint
éric bocquet que vous en pensez quoi
effectivement c'est cet article enfin
cette fois ce projet de loi va être
entre vos mains
au mois de janvier a priori
vous pensiez que d'ici là il pourrait
être supprimée ou pas je pense qu'il ya
pas d'autre choix
y'a pas de honte à retirer un article
qui et qui suscite autant d'oppositions
de tous les côtés on l'a vu dans les
rassemblements de la semaine dernière il
y avait de toutes les générations y
avait toutes les professions et je pense
que tout le monde était choqué de
l'ampleur de ces manifestations il n'y
avait pas des millions de gens mais il y
avait beaucoup plus de gens que prévu
sur un sujet comme celui là donc
l'émotion est grande et je me réjouis
qu'en fin de semaine on dise qu
effectivement c'est au parlement à
décrire la loi puisqu'il ya quelques
jours souvenez vous on avait inventé un
comité théodule et qui est chargée de
réécrire
je pense qu'il faut aller au delà de la
réécriture il faut abroger retirer et
refaire une réforme de fond sur cette
histoire de rapports police/population
cécile eyriac on a entendu aussi qu'il
était important de rétablir la confiance
avec les policiers demain il ya cette
deuxième manifestation pour réponse on
l'a vu dans les réactions sur les
réseaux sociaux le chef de l'état
propose la mise en place d'un numéro
vert pour dénoncer les violences
policières pour vous est-ce que c'est
suffisant le numéro vert et n'est pas
suffisant aujourd'hui parce qu'on voit
bien qu'il y à un véritable sujet de
confiance kiki rompu entre la population
et ses forces de l'ordre alors que les
forces de l'ordre dans leur le président
d'ailleurs l'a très bien dit elle sont
là où service de la sécurité de tous ce
qui est anormal aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
y ait des personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne se sentent pas en sécurité
face à ces forces de l'ordre donc il
faut qu'on puisse répondre d'une manière
positive au fait qu'aujourd'hui on ait
une certaine jeunesse et pas forcément
que des jeunes qui aujourd'hui ne se
sentent plus en sécurité face à ceux qui
sont censés les protéger
donc il faut à la fois trouver la
manière de protéger nos forces de
l'ordre parce que les scènes de violence
que l'on a vu à la fin de certaines
manifestations à l'encontre de nos
forces de l'ordre sont inacceptables au
même titre que les violences policières
à l'encontre
dû reporter d'ailleurs du journaliste
rémi buzine qui a interviewé le
président de la république aujourd'hui
comme les violences émises à l'encontre
de michel est clair voilà c'est c'est
insupportable c'est intolérable
donc on voit bien qu'il faut aujourd'hui
avancer sur ce sujet éric bocquet les
manifestants de demain réclame
d'ailleurs les jours les syndicats de
journalistes qui ont été reçus ce matin
par roselyne bachelot au ministère de
l'aide de la culture de l'undd aussi le
retrait du nouveau schéma du maintien de
l'ordre
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça je
pense qu'il est vraiment une réforme de
fond à mener celui où je préférerais
qu'on parle de gardiens de la paix comme
on faisait dans l'ancien monde
aujourd'hui on parle de forces de
l'ordre même si l'ordre est républicain
je préfère l'expression gardiens de la
paix il faut vraiment réfléchir au
recrutement au niveau des jeunes
policiers au niveau de leur formation
également il ya certainement des
problèmes de formation des problèmes
d'éthique
ça fait partie de la formation c'est pas
que la matraque il faut également
réfléchir à l'armement ou confits assez
à ses forces de l'ordre à ses gardiens
de la paix telles que j'aimerais qu'on
les appelle
souvenez-vous les débats qui a pu avoir
sur le l'utilisation dlb des
condamnations en france et ailleurs
d'ailleurs au moment du mouvement des
gilets jaunes a vécu des scènes quand
même affligeante et inquiétante
il faut absolument éviter de glisser
progressivement vers un état qui ne
serait plus à l'état de droit
reste un état qui est vu par certains
comme un état de plus en plus
autoritaire votre réaction et cécile
réac aa77 ce constat virait jeu
aujourd'hui je vais partir d'un sujet
qu'on est en train de travailler à son
national il ya une commission d' enquête
à la demande de nos collègues
socialistes justement sur la doctrine du
maintien alors je fais partie de cette
commission d' enquête sur lequel nous
sommes nous auditionnons énormément
nombre par rapport au nouveau schéma
directeur de la sécurité publique y est
le fait qu'il y ait un nouveau schéma
directeur
ça c'est ça a été une évidence suite au
mouvement il faut pas oublier des gilets
ghosn qui a démarré en novembre 2018 il
fait suivre il fait suite à cela ce
nouveau schéma parce qu'on s'est bien
aperçu qu'il est y avait une
problématique entre des nouveaux modèles
de manifestations des manifestants qui
étaient de plus en plus aussi violent et
qu'il fallait sécuriser nos
manifestations a pour les participants
eux-mêmes et et ensuite comment est-ce
qu'on encadrer les sorties de cortège
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a
véritablement on débat aujourd'hui et
les parlementaires sont saisis de là à
dire qu'il faut complètement supprimé le
schéma du maintien de l'ordre le nouveau
schéma
non par contre ce que l'on collègues
parlementaires disait ça a été soulevé
lors de nos auditions il y a en effet
une problématique de la formation parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des nouveaux
policiers qui sont sur le terrain qui du
fait justement de deux années de
tensions importantes n'ont peut-être pas
eu suffisamment de formation
particulièrement à à ces exercices du
maintien de l'ordre qui est un vrai
sujet sur la formation à avoir auprès de
nos policiers et là où je rejoins aussi
mon collègue sénateur on a une
interrogation sur l'utilisation de
certaines armes de certaines armes parce
que ce sont des armes aux dans le
maintien de l'ordre
ça c'est certain mais le schéma n'est
pas forcément à rediscuter parce qu'au
contraire dans ce nouveau schéma il y à
une prise en compte des nouvelles
modalités des manifestants et ça c'est
important d'en tenir compte
il ya une évolution aussi des
manifestations donc tout ça doit évoluer
dans le temps
dans la même logique emmanuel macron
lors de son interview à as brut éric
bocquet a longuement parlé des jeunes
des difficultés de la jeunesse
aujourd'hui à cause de la crise
sanitaire notamment
il promet une revalorisation en tout cas
des aides à leur intention
c'est essentiel selon vous en tout cas
c'est essentiel mais c'est éric bocquet
oui comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure on est dans le débat budgétaire
en ce moment au sénat il ya quelques
jours nous proposions avec d'autres
collègues la création d'un rsa jeunes
18-25 ans
parce que la prime de 150 euros pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa
quand on voit ce qui se passe dans
l'évident universités les reportages
affluent régulièrement pour montrer que
les étudiants qui ont des faibles
ressources n'auraient plus à faire face
ils n'ont plus les petits boulots qui
pouvait avoir avant la crise et qui
permettait de financer leurs études
aujourd'hui sont contraints d'aller
s'alimenter dans les banques
alimentaires dans les permanences du
secours populaire du secours catholique
on en est vraiment là donc c'est une
catégorie particulièrement touché par la
crise aujourd'hui au niveau financier au
niveau social au niveau psychologique
aussi m'ont vraiment il faut aller très
très loin en matière de solidarité
vis-à-vis de ces jeunes population y vit
dans un monde compliqué dans un monde
difficile et qui sont un peu en train de
perdre l'espoir en l'avenir
et ça c'est grave pour une société oui
c'est vraiment cela c'est cet espoir qui
est érodée à cause de cette crise
sanitaire cécile relax votre réaction
de là même de la même manière c'était
essentiel que le président de la
république s'adresse à notre jeunesse
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a une jeunesse
et pas seulement les étudiants on a
aussi ceux qui sont en amont des lycéens
qui se posent aussi énormément de
questions sur leur avenir et c'est vrai
qu'on a aujourd'hui donc toute cette
cette jeunesse qui n'arrive pas à se
projeter et on doit véritablement les
accompagner dont dans cette projection
dans l'avenir
aujourd'hui on a des étudiants qui sont
obligés d'aller au prendre des colis
alimentaires
on a des étudiants qui depuis des mois
sont séparés de leurs familles qui ont
dû eu du mal à faire des allers-retours
parce qu'il ya le confinement on a
également énormément de jeunes étudiants
particulièrement dans des universités
qui ont décroché de leurs études et donc
il va ya il va falloir que la sortie de
cette crise sanitaire
on est à un accompagnement de nos jeunes
dans leurs études et dans leur recherche
aussi de premier emploi
parce qu'aujourd'hui lorsque vous avez
vécu le confinement comme n'avait
peut-être pas pu aller au bout de vos
diplômes va vous avez énormément
d'interrogations vous ne savez pas de
quoi demain demain sera fait donc il
faut absolument que nous prenons en
compte la détresse et vos collègues
sénateurs l'a très bien dit à l'est elle
vraiment
tridimensionnelle il ya la détresse
financière actuelle il ya une véritable
détresse aussi sociale mais il ya aussi
un impact psychologique qui est très
très important et ça et on ne peut pas
le le diminuer l'amoindrir c'est un
enjeu capital pour l'avenir
merci beaucoup c'est cyril acquis et
merci à vous et reebok et d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions en
direct sur arte france